[Müzik]
Dostlar Hoşgeldiniz Az önce yapılan
sunumu ben Şaka yapıyorlar zannetmiştim
içeride bir tekrar oldu değil miyiz
Şimdi sizlerle birlikte olduğum için
gerçekten çok mutluyum Ankara'nın benim
yerim gözümde bambaşka bir değeri var
hatta o kadar ilginç bir tesadüf ki şu
anda telex konuşmasını Yaptığım bu
binanın hemen karşısında bir Tepe var
Ben orada doğdum ve orada büyüdüm tabii
şimdi yerinde Gökdelenler var hatta
hikayede de paylaştım
22 yıldır teknoloji anlatıyorum 22
yıllık bu serüven içerisinde teknoloji
bizi nereden aldı nereye doğru götürüyor
bu bilinmez yolculukta Size bazı
bilgiler vereceğim
açıkçası benim ilk internet ve
bilgisayarla buluşma hikayemi anlatmak
istiyorum size Çünkü benim şu anda hitap
ettiğim kişiler arasında
zannetmiyorum ki doğduğunda internet Ya
da bilgisayar olmasın o evde
zannediyorum tamamında vardı belki tek
tük büyüklerimiz var böyle Kafayı
sallayanlar Şimdi size bazı bilgileri
hatırlatacağım
Ben ilk defa internette 16 yaşında
tanıştım 16 yaşında ben üniversiteyi
kazandım Sakarya Üniversitesi'ne gittim
orada bir internet laboratuvarı açıldı
ben o internet laboratuvarına gittiğimde
internette teknolojiye bilgisayarlara
aşık oldum Benim ilk buluşmam 16 yaşında
ve oradaki Memura dedim ki senden bir
isteğim var Sana bir önerim var bu
Önerim Sen saat beşte burayı
kilitliyorsun gidiyorsun sen Anahtarı
bana bırak ben burayı paspaslarım
bilgisayarların da formatını atarım
güncellerim bakımında yaparım Sadece
burayı bana bırak o da kabul etti ve ben
internette buluştum saatler geçiriyorum
gece yarıları kalıyorum hatta gece
yarıları en geç saatte
ulaşım yok Bazen yürüyerek iniyorum O
Sakarya Üniversitesi kampüsünden eve
doğru ve acayip hayal kurdum arkadaşlar
16 yıl 16 yaşındayken bahsediyorum bu
hayallerden
Ne hayal kurdum biliyor musunuz ya dedim
bu internet mükemmel bir şey Niye ben
üniversitede bir araştırma yapıyorum bu
araştırma yaptıktan sonra ne yapıyorum
bir makale hazırlıyorum bu makaleyi de
internette yayınlıyorum
internette yayınladıktan sonra
benim
yazdığım bu makalenin üzerine başka bir
ülkedeki bir bilim insanı
kendi geliştirmelerini yapıyor ve bu
geliştirmelerden sonra o da kendi
makalesini internete koyuyor bu sefer
atıyorum Japonya'dan bir başka bilim
insanında bu makaleyi alıyor İnsanlık
adına bir geliştirme yapıyor ve bu
geliştirmeyi insanlığa sunuyor
Yani kısaca bir iki oluyor iki üç oluyor
taş üstüne taş koyuyoruz Sadece bu
bahsettiğim şey bilimsel gelişmeler de
değil yani bugün bir dünya klasiği
okuduğunuzu düşünün Bu sizin için çocuk
oyuncağı ama ben bu doğduğum topraklarda
O zamandan bahsediyorum yani eğer
kütüphaneye bir erişiminiz yoksa ya da
maddi imkanınız yoksa sizin bu dünya
klasiklerine ulaşmanız da çok zordu
şimdi durum böyle olunca internet bana
bir sürü hayal kurdurdu bu Hayaller
arasında iyiliğin yayılması güzelliğin
yayılması da vardı ama bu 22 yıllık
süreç içerisinde
maalesef işler planlandığı gibi gitmedi
geldiğimiz noktaya baktığımızda
gerçekten çok ciddi güçlü hızlı
internete sahibiz çok inanılmaz
cihazlara sahibiz Az önce benim de
sunumumu yaparlarken şimdi buradaki
güçlü cihazlara rağmen Geldiğimiz
noktada benim o kurduğum Hayallerde
şöyle bir gelecek düşünmüştüm Afrika'da
açlar vardı dedim ki bu İnternet
sayesinde acayip keşifler oluyor
geliştirmeler oluyor o zaman biz şu anda
İçinde bulunduğumuz ülkemizde de çok
ciddi bir israf söz konusu gelişmiş
Ülkelerde de çok ciddi bir israf söz
konusu burada böyle israf varken acaba
Afrika'daki aç insanlara buradaki fazla
yiyecekler gıdalar hızlı bir şekilde
ulaştırılır mı diye bir hayal kururken
Geldiğimiz noktada işte bir füze çok
Uzaktaki bir kıtaya çok daha hızlı nasıl
ulaşır ulaştığı yerde nasıl infilak eder
bunun geliştirmesi yapılıyor ve en çok
alkışlanan konularda Maalesef bu tür
teknolojik gelişmeler Ama ben umudumu
yitirmedim slaytımın sonunda da bunları
sizlere paylaşacağım
Şimdi biz teknolojiyi insanlığa mutluluk
getirsin diye üretmeye geliştirmeye
başlamıştık ben de ya dedim bu teknoloji
mükemmel bir şey teknolojiye editörü
olarak anlatayım o zaman insanlara
insanlar günlük hayatını daha verimli
daha mutlu geçirsin şimdi mutluluk diye
bir kelimeden bahsediyoruz mutluluğun
tanımını bir yapalım arkadaşlar
mutluluğun teknolojik olarak bir tanımı
yok ama tarif edebiliriz sadece Teknik
olarak destek alabileceğim bir konu var
o da Mutluluk Aslında hormonlar sonucu
elde edilen bir şey Ama bu hormonlardan
bahsetsek çok iyi olur Mesela bu
hormonlarla iyi geçinmemiz lazım
bunlardan bir tanesi serotoni serotonin
güvende gelen bir hormon Güven nedir
bazısına göre Güven internet
bankacılığına girersiniz orada bazı
rakamlar görürsünüz o rakamlar pozitifse
Siz kendinizi güvende hissedersiniz veya
şu an soğuk bir ortamdayız Eğer sıcak
bir yuvanın içerisindeyseniz kendinizi
güvende hissedersiniz ve bu hormon
ortaya çıkar bir diğer hormon oksitosin
Bu da sosyal olduğunuzda yani hayatımın
sonuna kadar ben bu insanla beraber
olmak istiyorum dediğinizde o insan
yanınızdaysa bu hormon salgılanıyor ve
siz mutlu oluyorsunuz veya ailenizle
beraber bir yemek yerken bir başka
hormon endorfin en doğru filin
acılarınız yok olurken salgılanan diyor
hormon bir diğer hormonumuzda
dopamin dopaminde hareket halinde
salgılanan bir hormon
Şimdi burada bu hormonlarla beraber bir
mutluluk üretiliyorsa o zaman biz
dopaminle başlayabiliriz harekete
geçmeyle başlayabiliriz
nasıl harekete geçtiğimi de bir anlatmak
istiyorum size İşte benim sunumumu
yaparken dediler ki Türkiye'nin en büyük
teknoloji yayını kurdu Evet bu yayını
kurarken çok enteresan bir hikayem var
çok hızlıca bahsedeceğim size bir
dergide çalışıyorum dergide çalışırken
İnternetimiz telefonla bağlanarak
gerçekleşiyor 2000'li yılların
başlarından bahsediyorum ve İstanbul'a
ADSL geldi hızlı internet geldi dedim ki
ben bu hızla internette bir araştırayım
bulayım kalktım ofisten çıktım bir
operatörün
binasının önüne gittim bir baktım acayip
bir sıra var ya dedim ki acaba telefon
faturalarını ödemek için mi geldiler
Aslında hayır
oraya gelme sebepleri Tamamen benim gibi
hızlı internet Şimdi hızlı internet için
gelen kişilere soruyorum mesela diyorum
ki niye geldiniz bazısı diyor ki işte
daha fazla ıelsi değil sohbetleri yapmak
istiyorum eğer siz sohbetin ne olduğunu
bilen var mı
bilen bir iki kişi var bu videoyu
izleyenler arasında da yorum
yapacaklardır eminim işte ondan sonra
Divx indirmek için geldim diyenler var
divx'in ne olduğunu bilen var mı yine o
iesiyi bilenler bunun biraz sayısı
artmıştır yani o zaman böyle bizim bu
film izlediğimiz platformlar pek yok O
nedenle bu dilixler falan çok popüler
indirmek için vesaire Ondan sonra ben
acayip şaşırdım harekete geçtikten sonra
bu olayları görünce bu bilgiyi sahadan
alınca döndüm Dergiye dedim ki bir
internet sitesi kurmamız gerekiyor Bu
kuracağımız internet sitesi Kesinlikle
bizim derginin yerini almalı Yani bu
değişime bu dönüşüme bizim ayak
uydurmamız lazım Peki bu dönüşüme ayak
uydurmada ne yapacaksın bize anlat
dediler Ben dedim ki derginin
sayfalarında anlattığımız
dergiyi satarak insanlara verdiğimiz
bilgi ücretsiz web sitesinde verelim
sonra dediler ya dedim bu derginin
yapraklarında görseller var bu
görselleri Biz video ile anlatalım Allah
Allah çok ilginç sonra sonra dedim ki
bizim dergiyi Biz teslim ediyoruz
okuyucuya sonra okuyucudan haberimiz yok
gerçi bazıları mektup yazıyordu o zaman
hatırlıyorum o zaman diyor ki Aa dergi
hakkında böyle düşünüyorlar ya da sonra
e-postaya başladılar Ben dedim ki
yazdığımız haberlerin makalelerin altına
insanlar yorum Yazsınlar
sonuç ne oldu biliyor musunuz bir daha
bizim karşımıza böyle saçma sapan
fikirlerle çıkma denildi kabul etmediler
ve ben daha sonra kendi yayınımı kurdum
Şu anda Geldiğimiz noktada sunum
yaptığım dostlarımın eski dostlarımın
kurmuş olduğu bu dergiyle kendi
yayınımızı kıyasladığımızda arada 100
kat kadar fark var arkadaşlar
burada
şöyle bir bilgi vermek istiyorum size
teknoloji ilerledikçe hepimiz daha mutlu
oluruz diye biz düşündük
teknolojiyi hayatımızda Kullandıkça daha
fazla verimli daha refah daha bereketli
bir dünya olur diye düşündük ama
bu süreci bir yakından bakalım
isterseniz kendimizi teknoloji
Kullandıkça duygularımızı da o
ekranlardan ifade ediyoruz işte
dokunmatik ekranlı telefonlarımızdan
yazıyoruz yazamadıklarımızda Emoji
gönderiyoruz duygularımızı ifade ederken
en çok kullandığımız Emoji bu Yalnız bu
emojiyi en son ne zaman gönderdiğinizi
bir düşünün
ve şunu fark edeceksiniz Bu çok acı bir
tespit Bu emojiye gönderirken karşı
taraf ne düşünüyor yani o kadar güldü ki
gözlerinden yaş çıktı ama bu emojiyi
gönderirken İnsanların çoğunun yüzünde
en ufak bir oynama yok
şu anda birazcık geldi gülümsemeler ama
hak veriyorsunuz bana değil mi Gerçekten
bu emojiyi gönderirken en ufak bir
oynama yok Kullanmadığımız kaslar var ve
bizim bu kasları biraz harekete
geçirmemiz gerekiyor şimdi ben bunu bir
tehlikeymiş gibi anlatıyorum size Ama bu
sadece benim tespitim değil bu
teknolojiyi geliştiren Devlerin de
tespiti işte iOS işletim sistemini
geliştiren dev bir marka var Hemen
rakibi Android işletim sistemini
geliştiren bir başka dev marka var
onları yeni yeni rakipleri var Bunlar da
geldiğimiz bu noktadaki Tehlikenin
farkında Mesela bu işletim sistemleri
ilk duyurulduğuna haberini Ben yaptım 22
yıldır bu sektördeyim bu işletim
sistemlerinin ilk çıktığı andaki
haberini yaptım
bu haberleri yaparlarken o teknoloji
şirketleri ne diyordu biliyor musunuz
Lütfen bu işletim sistemini kullanın
lütfen akıllı telefona geçin lütfen bu
cihazlara uygulama indirin günlük
hayatta yaptığınız işleri bu uygulamadan
yapın günlük hayatta ne ihtiyacın var
eğitim Tamam buradan yap Neye ihtiyacın
var spor koy ekranı karşına buradan yap
Neye ihtiyacın var sosyallik eğlence
hepsine bu ekranlardan yap uygulamayı
indir Peki en başta çok güzel gelen bu
hikayeler
Geldiğimiz noktada o şirketleri de
rahatsız etmeye başladı Şu anda yeni
işletim sistemleri ile beraber bizlere
bazı uyarılar veriliyor mesela bunlardan
bir tanesi ekran süresi ekran
sürelerinde bir kısıtlama söz konusu
diyorlar ki yeter artık hatta
uygulamalara
sınırlandırma var Yani bu işletim
sistemleri ilk duyurulduğunda bunları
yapacakları Sözde herkes gülerdi şu anda
işte Instagram'da sen günde 3 saat
geçirdin diyelim kendine kısıtlama
getirebiliyorsun bu işletim
sistemlerinde diyorlar ki dur artık
şimdi bunların hepsinin farkında olmamız
gerekiyor
ve önlem olarak ne yapabiliriz aslında
bir öğretimiz var bizim yani biz İslam
dininde oruç olarak tanıdık işte başka
başka inançlarda işte Detoks diyen var
diyet diyen var aslında bu gerçekten çok
mükemmel bir tavsiye teknoloji editörü
olarak söylüyorum bakın 22 yıllık bu
teknoloji yayıncılığı hayatımda hep
insanlara teknoloji kullanmalarını
tavsiye ettim teknolojileri anlattım
dünyada bu teknolojiyi geliştiren dev
şirketler Türkiye'den çağırdı beni bizim
teknolojilerimize dene ve daha sonra
anlat takipçilerine diye ayda 24 milyon
milyonu bir platformun kurucusu olarak
söylüyorum cumartesi günleri
teknolojiden uzak durmaya çalışıyorum
kesinlikle bunu deneyin neden Aslında
yapmaya çalıştığımız şey şu Ben
teknolojinin kötü olduğunu söylemiyorum
teknoloji ilk tanıştığım andaki
teknoloji teknoloji değişmedi ama bizim
ona yaklaşma ve kullanma tarzımız
değişti amaçlarımız farklı olduğu için
teknolojinin adı Kötüye Çıktı bunu
düzeltecek olan da bizi Zone eden ve
teknolojiden biraz uzak kalıp onu
özleyip daha sonra yeniden
Buluştuğumuzda çok daha mükemmel bir
buluşma yapabiliriz diye düşünüyoruz
Şimdi burada amacımız mutlu olmaktı
mutlu olurken
seçebileceğimiz iki tane platform var
bir tanesi gerçek hayat Yani şu anda biz
yüz yüze bir sahnede karşı karşıyayız
arada böyle Beraber fotoğraf
çektirdiğimiz dostlarımız oldu Ben şu
kadar yıldır Aboneyim diyenler oldu Çok
mutlu oldum Gerçekten birincisi bu
platformda mutlu olunabilir ikincisi
sanal bir ortamda da mutlu olunabilir
şimdi ikincisini Biraz hızlı açacağım
iki tane şirket var Bunlardan bir tanesi
ilan baskının nöralin şirketi nurel'in
şirketini bilen var mı aranızdan baya
bir el kalktı süper Harikasınız nurel'in
şirketinde beyne böyle kafatasının
altına yerleştirilen bir çip
sizin o çipi yöneten sistem tarafından
hissetmeniz gereken duyguların
hissedilmesini sağlıyor Yani az önce
bahsettiğim bu hormonları oradan bir
tuşa basarak hissedebilirsiniz Ama şu
anda denemeler henüz hayvanların
üzerinde yapılıyor maalesef ve olumsuz
sonuçlar var henüz başarılmadı ikinci
seçenek sanal ortamda bize o mutluluğu
verebilecek olan ikinci seçenekten
bahsediyorum Facebook WhatsApp Instagram
bunların çatı şirketi olan bir şirket
var Bu şirket bir sanal gerçeklik
gözlüğü geliştirmeye çalışıyor ve 3
evrede Hatta bugün ayın 23'ü 23 Ekim 2
gün sonra ilk sipariş verenler teslim
alacaklar onlara da bir tanesi de benim
Mecburen
o sanal gerçekliğinin üçüncü evresinde
bu mutluluğu verebilir miyiz diye
düşünüyorlar Çünkü Birincisinde yaptılar
ya dediler çok başımız ağrıyor Midemiz
bulanıyor ikincisini geliştirdiler ya
burada sesler ve görüntüler çok daha iyi
anlaşılabilir miydi şimdi üçüncüsünü
geliştiriyorlar işte takan kişinin çok
daha rahatsız olmaması için mesela
hanımefendiler o gözlüğü takmaya çalışan
saçı başı dağılıyordu vesaire bunu
çözmeye çalışıyorlar ama halen
başaramadılar
teknoloji devlerinin insanlara vermeye
sağladığı bu mutluluk için halen
mücadele devam ediyor ama tekrar
dönüyorum seçenek olarak bize gerçek
hayat kalıyor gerçek hayatta teknoloji
dediğimiz kavramdan Bazen uzaklaşıp onu
özledikten sonra gerçek hayattaki
detayların farkına vardıktan sonra
yeniden teknolojiyle buluşabilirsiniz
Ben şu an beni izleyen izleyicilerin
kaç tanesinin ayakkabısına bakmadan
söylemesini istiyorum bağcığının rengini
biliyor bilenler el kaldırabilir mi
çoğunuz biliyorsunuz ama Bilmeyenler de
şu anda ciddi bir orana sahip bizi
izleyenler arasında da bu nedir
bilmiyorum bu detaylardan çok
uzaklaşıyoruz Tabii ki ayakkabı bağcığı
böyle çok küçük bir detaydı ama işte
oturduğumuz koltuğun rengi halının
desene Etraftaki ağacın türü türünü
bilmiyorsak bir araştırsak acaba bu ağaç
nereden geldi Buraya bunun gibi
gerçekler bizi çok daha mutlu edebilir
diye düşünüyoruz ve sunumun sonunda
tekrar şunu söylemek istiyorum 16 yıl
önce tanıştığım Bilgisayar ve internet
ve beraberinde gelen teknoloji
Kesinlikle o gün kurduğum hayalleri
gerçekleştirecek
Afrika'da aç insanlar var bir tarafta
israf var
çok güzel eserler var Kendi bölgemizden
mezopotamya'dan çıkan çok güzel çok
kıymetli eserler var başka başka
ülkelerde olan eserler de var iyilik
güzellik refah Bereket eminim dünyanın
tamamına bu teknoloji ile yayılacak ve
bu teknolojiyi geliştiren kişilerde
Türkiye'den çıkacak örneklerini görmeye
başladık başladıkça ben çok mutlu
oluyorum Daha burada kendi Sıramı
Beklerken hemen Birileri geldi ben böyle
bir şey yaptım dedi onları denedim ben
denerken onların gözündeki sevinci
gördüm kesinlikle ben bu topraklardan
teknolojinin bilgisayarın internetin
dünyanın huzuru için kullanılacak
insanlara çıkacağına inanıyorum beni
dinlediğiniz için çok teşekkür ederim
sağ olun
teşekkür ederim
[Müzik]
[Alkış]